madame monsieur bonsoir les alliés ont
donc mis leur menace à exécution tout à
l'heure une opération militaire aérienne
très rapide trois heures environ contre
l'irak avec la participation de mirage
2000 français nous y reviendrons en
détail dans un instant ce ne sont pas
tant les incursions répétées d'irakiens
dans la zone démilitarisée qui agace et
les occidentaux que la mise en place de
patrie missiles menaçant les autres
avions alliés chargée de protéger les
régions habitées par les kurdes
commentaire de france au cornet sur des
images de reconstitution on peut
raisonnablement penser que les attaques
aériennes des alliés contre les
objectifs irakien a été synchronisé que
les avions de combat américains français
britanniques ont décollé simultanément
de la base de dharan en arabie saoudite
peut être de celles d'in ces reliques en
turquie et d'un porte avions américain
depuis la méditerranée
depuis plusieurs jours les forces
aériennes alliées étaient en état d'
alerte cette information avait été
confirmée ce matin par pierre joxe
le ministre de la défense qui s'est
rendu récemment sur place les premiers
objectifs détruits par l'aviation alliée
sont les rampes de missiles mobiles que
nous allons voir dans un instant sam 2
et sam 3 qui avait été déployé sur le
32e parallèle au sud de l'irak il ya une
quinzaine de jours et durant le week-end
dernier au nord du 36e près de la ville
de mossoul
on n'a pas toutefois confirmation que
ceux du nord et bien été attaqué ce que
l'on sait pour l'instant c'est que les
avions ont bien décollé de la base de
dharan et du porte-avions kitty hawk ces
chasseurs bombardiers américains et les
chasseurs bombardiers britanniques
tornado étaient appuyés par une
couverture aérienne à laquelle
participaient les mirage 2000 français
qui ont décollé de taran en arabie
saoudite
et cela a été confirmé de source
militaire
dans la soirée à paris les rampes de
missiles irakiens avait été localisée
avec précision par les satellites
américains leur destruction était prévue
pour lundi dernier mais l'opération
avait dû être reporté en raison des
mauvaises conditions météo dans la
région du golfe
la maison blanche avait affirmé qu'il
n'y aurait pas d' avertissement
préalable avant ce raid
il fallait faire jouer l'effet de
surprise de façon à ne laisser aucune
chance aux irakiens de replier leurs
rampes de missiles
les avions alliés n'aurait effectué
qu'une seule frappe l'attaquent aurait
duré en tout et pour tout qu'une la vie
libre nos trois heures y compris le
transat ne transite par dans tous les
avions alliés sont actuellement sur le
chemin du retour et les forces aériennes
américaines françaises et britanniques
n'auraient subi dans cette opération
aucune perte